[Music]
well hey guys what you got there kid no
you find anything like this on my wiki
viscous wiki's are obsolete or Johnna
what is this what the tesseract how can
that be
it's from another dimension there's
another dimension well then we should
put it somewhere safe
no I've got a better idea Tree Hill
Oh
in the hands of mortals the tesseract
will only cause great harm you must
return it to us at once I'm no mortal
the tesseract is ours so be it and we
fight this is too easy
bring it J littler cap kill Hitler after
this one
[Music]
fools
gotta catch'em oh there is me buddy
[Music]
chief what do I do the coalition's but
buddies just fight
you gotta you gotta save the world
I already did
[Music]
nope
hey thanks for watching the video the
guys from buff dudes and vsauce3 were
awesome to work with and you should
definitely check out their channels also
this video is made possible by our
patrons if you like our work consider
supporting us on patreon and help us
make even more epic videos
[Music]